what's happening you savages it's
wednesday the 12th of january the joint
is brought to you by i want to welcome
back
expressvpn
using the internet without expressvpn is
like leaving your keys in the car while
you're running to the store why would
you do that yeah you might be safe but
chances are before you know it your
car's being stripped apart two towns
over you wouldn't risk your car so don't
risk your personal info either it
doesn't take much to know how to hack
someone a 12 year old can do it that's
why i use
express bpm my wife and i both use it
it's easy to use and it's tremendous
it's fast
listen with expressvpn hackers can't
steal your sensitive data i take a
hacker with a supercomputer over a
billion years to get past
expressvpn
encryption it's easy to use fire up the
app click one button to get protected
and it works on all devices phones
laptops tablets and more so you can stay
secure on the go
secure your online data today
by visiting expressvpn.com
joey that's j-o-e-y that's
expressvpn.com
joey and you get an extra three months
for free
expressvpn.com
joey the joint is also brought to you by
these [__] are the best in the
business draftkings
listen i know you want some money with
the national championship unlike your
uncle joey you took georgia god bless
you i took [__] alabama those
[__] but anyway counting down the
super bowl 56 new customers can get
56 to one odd on any wild card team to
win their game
excuse me that means that if you bet the
fin five dollars you win 280 and free
bets if your team is victorious if
sportsbook isn't available in your state
yet don't sweat the small stuff
everyone can play huge cash prizes with
draftkings dallasy fantasy football
contest draftkings is giving all new
customers a free shot at millions of
dollars
in total prize with their first deposit
download the draftking sportsbook app
today use promo code joey j-o-e-y and
get 56-1 odds on any nfl team just bet 5
hours and win 280 and free bets if your
team wins that's promo code joey j-o-e-y
this wild car week at draftkings
sportsbook app an official sports
betting partner of the nfl now you got
to be 21 older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania west virginia colorado
listen to me there's a hope check a
bunch of states check them if not
download the fantasy app but here you go
new customers only minimum final deposit
on a dollar wager required
one per customer don't get cute
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gaming problem call 1-800 gamble but if
not head over to draftking download the
app and let's win some [__]
cash all right we're coming at you from
a different angle but the candles always
lick [__]
hey
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
january the 12th
your [__] uh
33 days from getting your pipe licked on
valentine's day
[__] write down your goals let's
start the podcast with eight
bobby saget is dead and i don't feel so
good myself rip
to bob saget he was a [__] great
comedian
uh i didn't get to post my picture up
with him and me
smiling when i saw everybody else doing
it i figured i want a different
direction i don't even have a picture of
me and bob saget i was at the store for
23 years and i met him probably
in 1998
at the front bar
i was waiting for a package
he used to come up at night a car would
drop him off and he'd stay there in
front and talk the comics and he would
go up and that's the first time i met
him and i found him to be [__] a
great guy i think he gave me advice we
because he's a dirty comic
so uh i went to him in 98 and asked him
some questions at the bar
and he said i'll come watch you you know
and a couple weeks later he popped up
again he said to me hey man
that's the way to [__] do comedy he
goes mitzi and you go yeah and we just
went down the [__] hotline and then
a little while after that he got into
stand-up back into stand-up i'm sorry
and he would hang out down there he was
down there with us on tuesday nights he
did all the crazy shows
and uh it's a shame that the world is
where it is right now
and that they found them and i dug
yesterday i saw a lot of that great
tributes for bob saget but i saw some
people posting some rotten [__] and like
i always say the world's in a [__] up
place right now i never saw that guy get
high i never saw him drink i never
listened i never went out with him i
never did any projects with him
but i knew him from the store and i knew
he was a comedy store [__] savage and
here's my favorite story like
years ago i had hbo like everybody else
like for years i had hbo no matter where
i moved whose house i was living in they
always had [__] hbo and that's
when i saw those rodney things you know
like it
i could lie i don't know what [__]
year it was i know
i know it was before i got locked up
let's just say that before the
kidnapping bk right
so
i saw him stand up was nowhere in my
[__] world
uh it was a
rodney dangerfield type thing and you
guys know i was always a rodney fan
so i watched it because of that
and he had a great [__] set and i
never knew his name
i never knew nothing
and then they threw a curveball at me
they [__] he was on america's
funniest videos
so i saw him on hbo talking about
disasters
and now he's got a suit and glasses on
he's and then he was on the other show
in full house and then felicia would did
an episode of that show so that's how
you know so i was always a fan of his
but honestly i became a super fan of his
when i saw him do spots at the store
because he's one of me i'm one of him
and uh i hope he's up there with mitzi
[__] laughing and giggling
uh rest in peace to his family my heart
goes out to his family and his children
you know the [__] deal guys but i'm
not gonna post a [__] picture of me
and him behind the car that just you
know it's getting it's getting crazy out
there people we gotta show you what
we're about now you can see i switched
[__] corners my mother used to tell
me don't hang out in corners for too
long so we switched it around i got
bruce lee i got
[__] me and my mom there we got the
youtube we got the [__]
75 shot
to plot to kill fidel up in northern new
jersey i got in the paper right there
nobody could tell me nothing we got the
adam sandler and we got [__]
spider-ham spider-man 2
that's not no way home but [__] it
hopefully they'll throw me a residual
something i saw you people
saying that you want to be in the
spider-man and brought [__] uh hope
to the world you know you were supposed
to have a petition well
it failed that's what i'm trying to tell
you your [__]
your petition went kaput all right
[__] because i never got the call
for spiderman unless they're gonna zoom
me in there
like a little picture of me on over a
chubby [__] body you know what i'm
saying
but no the bob saget thing that you know
it did bother me guys
to the extent that hey he was a comedy
store guy
but b
that's what i always [__] dreaded
listen man we're all gonna [__] die
you could pick your own medicine right
or wrong you can pick your own money you
could die in the street with a [__]
gun in your hand
you could die in your [__] bed
surrounded by
people who were waiting for three for
you to die so they could steal that
[__] pool table from 19 21 you got in
your basement you know you know those
people that come as you're getting ready
to die i know we all did it one time we
milked somebody on their last leg told
them how much we loved them we wanted to
move up from the patio fan and furniture
maybe for a gold watch or something it's
a [__] shame what people do after
people that but that
that's not what i'm [__] saying
listen
i don't want to die in a hotel room that
was my biggest fear
when i was doing coke that i would die
in a hotel room
and you wouldn't find me for two days my
feet would get to stinking you know what
i'm saying you come in there and have a
purple mark on my [__] heart and your
feet are stinking the people come in
then what what smells worse like i
always think about that [__] so
you know what knock on wood uh
that deters me a little bit but uh rest
in peace bob sagan i mean
no problem
listen to me it's been such a [__]
bad year
they're about to have
and i wish i could go you know
this guy made my [__] career
jeff the piano player jeff scott rest in
peace is supposed to have a thing for
him
like on january 16th or something like
that i saw that
uh
you know this guy hasn't even dried yet
and here goes another soldier from the
comedy store going down so that's going
to be a [__]
really heartfelt but you know what
people need that right now i tell you if
there's ever a time for that [__]
it's the time right now trust me i
wouldn't go to that stuff
but if i was in la i'd be down there
sunday night
with my vaccination card you know
honoring [__] uh i'm gonna find out
if there's some way i can send flowers
or if he left the fun to send a little
money because jeff scott
was my [__] dog jeff scott
taught me
how to do [__] comedy
in the original room
and he always stayed on me and he gave
me great advice when i was there and
when jeff scott died last year guys i
was going through such a [__] hard
time in my life
i never got to absorb it until about six
months ago
when somebody told me on the phone that
they went to the store and the original
room is not the same without jeff scott
playing a [__] piano and i knew it i
knew it but i never really uh mourned
him at all
you know me and jeff used to just [__]
around on facebook and stuff like that i
didn't have his number he didn't have my
number or he yeah he called me once but
it was years ago
but i was thinking about that today how
that's going to be a [__] wild wake
uh memorial you know a lot of people
have fallen the last year you know
so i don't know what's going on you know
i ain't got the answers all i could do
is [__] make you giggle a little bit
for a half hour so and then you go back
to the [__] world you keep listening
to podcasts all day long i know that's
what i would do right now you know to
put a little humor in my life
i hope you i am happy you guys enjoyed
[__] stew finer uh
he's a great dude man he did some great
[__] things
he don't have to apologize to nobody
when i i stumbled upon stu and those
guys like i said in the uh interview
with stu i stumbled upon stu
and what they were doing like in 1992
that was like august of 92
and then i went back in 93.
guys let me be as honest as i can with
you
i got a couple of regrets
i don't regret nothing that i did i
think if i could do it all over again i
would do it what are you going to do
but i i regret not going into the army
but listen i only got thrown out in
three years
i would have made basic i was in shape
but i got through i didn't want to hear
about rules if they would have taken me
to japan or something i would have ended
up in a sucky sucky house
[__] stabbing people and [__] and
doing blow we all know the deal i mean
you know i have to [__] be honest
with myself here and uh
i got some [__] regrets you know but
one of them is not
listen
when i met those guys when i met stu and
kurt and all those guys
i
they [__] turned my life around like
at that you know that training period
that those first four weeks in august
were [__] phenomenal
phenomenal for a guy like me i had
somewhere to be now from 10 to six
you call people on the phone and harass
them that that's
that's what i'm all about you know what
i'm saying the more you say don't call
that's a green light for uncle joey so
that kind of job is all numbers it's the
more people you [__] call the more
people and you're faxing and you're you
know you're doing [__] you just listen
why don't i do this let me fax you this
i mean we were [__] nuts in that
office but it taught me how to work the
[__] phones it taught me discipline
it prepared me for comedy because it
takes away your weekends see i was one
of the lucky dudes in there there was 14
guys in that office
but only four of us were single
the other 10 guys had [__] mouths to
feed
kids boats these [__] were
getting paid
i mean it was uh
it gave you hope you know the first year
like i said i bottomed out i was awful
listen the whole time i worked i was all
[__] up on coke you know it's not like
i was doing coke in the daytime it was
the amount of coke i was doing at
nighttime
and during football season you know
you're making money
so
my party would start friday night you
know 11 o'clock go to a five you gotta
walk in that office at six
you gotta walk into the office at six
and you gotta be ready to yell at people
at 6 30 in the [__] morning yeah yeah
like grab your [__] card
but
it carry like it just it helped me out
i would do that and at the same time do
comedy because you only work till six
o'clock at night and on the weekends
yeah they had a show on friday nights
you stayed there till midnight at 11
o'clock but at that point in my comedy
career think about this [__] guys i was
doing comedy
and working there at the same time
i had it [__] down
so you figured i started in july 91 i
got separated in october in 91.
i was on the comedy tip and then all in
i was the house emcee at the [__]
broker in boulder i would go right from
the job to the broker like on tuesday
nights and half the guys will come with
me
so every monday night
win or lose every weekend during
football season
the manager the owner of that company
would take because stew was on long
island i was in boulder colorado with
these savages
stu this guy kurt would take us out
every monday night
we would vote on a bar in boulder they
had to have great [__] food and
tremendous appetizers
and that we'd take over a bar like he'd
get the whole back room for 17 of us 20
of us because some of the people who
worked in the office would come along
and we'd sit there from
seven o'clock to 11 eating drinking for
free he would pick up the whole [__]
tab
they were very professional
and they gave me hope at that time i had
just gone through a divorce
i was down on my dick you know i was
selling neon part-time whenever i
[__] woke up and this job grabbed me
and you heard the [__] hours there
was no [__] around there you couldn't
come in at seven and go your horse broke
down or you know your [__] hurts
no these guys were strong island
strong island mentality
jewish very very [__] going for the
kill you know last weekend i had a
sleepover here it was my daughter's
birthday on saturday
and uh because of the covet thing we
couldn't have the party in the pool hall
or but not a pool a bowling alley was
supposed to rent but when my wife got
there with the other mom
the bowling alley was shut because it
covered so
we just didn't want to you know [__]
throw it to the wall so we go you know
if you want to pick
four girls to sleep in the living room
we'll lay [__] uh have mattresses
down and [__]
and uh
you know
we'll uh the girls can sleep in the
living room we'll get some food i went
to chick-fil-a i bought like 90 [__]
chicken nuggets
i snuck like 10 of them in my pocket
those [__] chicken chicken nuggets
from
chicken fillet [__] top notch let me
tell you some chick-fil-a get your [__]
done quick
like don't ever [__] get the turret
at that place because of a line i don't
ever like standing on [__] lines but
chick-fil-a i know i'm getting my [__]
in six minutes those christians are tip
top [__] magoo over there
i love those christian [__]
[__] abortion [__] working sunday you
know these [__] are bad to the
bone over it
chick-fil-a i went there friday saturday
night i picked up 90 [__]
chicks [__] fries no lemonade not
like that they had a bunch of [__]
upstairs i come back anyway let's get to
the story joy what the [__] so
[Music]
i get back and uh
they're gonna go to sleep you know
they're up there [__] a lot i mean
i'm down here watching what i was
watching the honeymoon it was a late
christmas honeymoon it was on i said let
me stay up go [__] one and watch the
honeymooners i could you know they'll be
out cold [__] you
at one o'clock it sounded like studio 54
up in that [__] they put the tv
there's some music [__] like that kid's
disney
i don't even know what the song is it's
just it's the same chick singing
different songs and every song is worse
than the other but she's got like a kind
of a cute voice so anyway
i heard my i go upstairs about one
and about [__] three in the morning
and i see my
wife getting up
and she's got steam coming out of the
ears and when she comes back she's got
smoke coming out of her [__] ears
and i go what's the matter she goes you
you with that sleep apnea machine you
can't hear it those [__] girls out
there going [__] awol
and i got in here nothing she goes let
me tell you somebody had to take two of
them aside now there were six little
girls
and you know all nationalities all races
but there's one that's a [__] great i
love it a dad should play softball my
daughter a little jewish girl
hell on wheels that's why i love her you
know i'm saying like i don't wanna know
if that you know and they were all hell
on wheels don't get me [__] wrong
it's six nine year old it was four nine
year olds one ten year old and one 11
year old and they didn't [__] stop
so my wife comes back and she goes and
the girl's name
is like a [__] attorney
i go she's jewish what do you expect you
know what i'm saying she she was talking
my wife out of [__] and then she even
said my wife she goes you know what i
don't even like that you're in charge i
think joey should be in charge
[__] steam came and then the girl
goes let's take a vote to see who wants
joey to be in charge and three of the
girls raise their hand my wife crack
she's like go to bed i went right into
the room i didn't say a [__] word you
know i tried to be like my mother my
mother would always like if my kids over
forget it she would embarrass the [__]
out of me she'd [__] come out and ask
the kid if they wanted steaks do they
look like they want [__] steaks i
don't wanna and then she's like oh
you're hungry can't you just give us
potato chips no she'd make a [__]
t-bone steak before my [__] friends
with cuban rice bean and my friend you
know it was just embarrassing but i i
liked it i liked that she opened her
home
to my [__] goombas anyway to make a
long story short speaking of jews i was
talking about the jewish people that i
worked for
in [__] uh boulder colorado like they
were just
stu started out here in long island but
the other three brothers had an
interesting story
you know stu helped them out to get the
business going
these guys opened the business out of
that basement
and the first year within the mother
they had the mother
calling you know to get confirmations of
the credit cards and stuff and it was
the two brothers and the first year
working out of the basement they would
go from upstairs to downstairs and abs
like they had an office and nothing like
that
they made [__] like seven figures
when i heard that story you know that
was them and dolly i remember he used to
say some crazy [__] at the meetings he's
like and gentlemen we're working
christmas jesus was a jew
you know he would say that every [__]
year
but let me tell you the other hand of
that on the other hand
if you worked an off day like listen
saturday sunday
and monday they had you
that's a great place to work at not only
did you make money
but they had your lunch they had your
breakfast and they had your
mid-afternoon snack
so if you were hungry like at two
o'clock you'd get up go to the back and
get like a bagel with white fish
or [__] salmon they would have a
whole [__] salmon out and they would
get everything flown in from [__] new
york listen in my heart you know i'm all
in
so when they let me go to first year
they knew i had a drug problem they
didn't insult me
they didn't say bad to me they said come
back
when you get your head together
which is always very nice they knew what
i was going through
i was going through a horrible divorce i
was trying to make [__] ends meet
there was no end meeting and the most
frustrating thing was i wanted to do
comedy so i understand where you guys
are at when
you need to work because i had attorney
bills child support i was trying to get
back on my [__] feet but at the same
time i didn't want none of that [__]
i didn't care that i was broke i just
wanted to do [__] comedy you ever
feel like that like i just don't [__]
give a [__] why doesn't allison change
call me you know what i'm saying take me
on [__] door like guys i was so
[__] frustrated
but then i realized what i had i had
like a paid little scholarship to take
my time
i had to bulk up the boulder broker
which guaranteed me a spot
on tuesday night i had a little spot on
wednesday night i would go at the time
and i had a spot that's when i was doing
that [__] italian ball where the
[__] chubby dude came out and he was
a cook at first he'd give everybody
italian food and then he'd come back
dressed as [__] elvis impersonators
that's what i was going through in my
life so think about it i'm [__]
working at the sports center i'm doing
stand-up at night and my end [__] set
for the week thursday night you know how
i [__] went to bed on thursday night
i just opened up for a 500 pound fat
dude that was an elvis impersonator you
know how embarrassing that was for me
and i had to go back up there and close
the show and let me tell you something
the show opened they had like 20 people
but when the show closed they were down
to four he walked everybody
the food was good but once the food was
done are you going to take an air
beating from elvis not me
and i would have to go back out there
and say let's keep it going for whatever
his name was leonardo
and i would get in my car with that
small 50
and i would just want to [__] cry
because i wanted to do that every
goddamn night
the second year i ended on good [__]
terms with them like i went all the way
to february third he referred uh
an attorney for me to help me with my uh
to get my daughter to get decent
visitation hours
guys name was barry seiko out of bold
the guy had balls of steel
but there was just so much you could do
i was fanning this guy a lot of dough
you know that or that year they also
made me open up like an account and what
that account did for you was you started
putting money in there in august like
you put 100 away from me
a week and then once you start making
more money they wanted you to take
something out now when was the last time
you worked for an employer
that wanted you to take something out of
your paycheck because they actually
cared for you what they did was whatever
you put away by the end of the year they
would match
so during the offseason you had money
you know remember after sports after
[__] the nfl football
business tape is off by 60 percent your
big bulk of the year is what you make
on the nfl football college that's right
now we're in the middle of [__]
book making [__] mania you got
college basketball pro basketball
[__] hockey uh you know football
we're going into wild card weekend
college football just ended monday night
[__]
alabama let me down the crimson tide
those [__] suckers
i rode you out for 20 years i didn't i
don't give a [__] again they had like a
flat out of the pool i put it in on
monday i forgot who the [__] was playing
i'm i'm into this [__] why i mean my
wife started watching the wire from
scratch listen there's nothing on tv no
more i can't i can't do it guys you
[__] morons telling me to watch that
show with the three little white trash
[__] from newark robbing people
you know that no i don't know these
people that you got you never saw this
show on hbo
these three little white trash
[__] in newark they're robbing
they're doing drugs you know they junkie
dudes i might have bumped into them in
the 80s
it's a real show but the dog they lost
me with the first episode when he
smacked the girlfriend
like i couldn't watch anymore
but then i realized it was 1980
everybody was kicking people in the
stomach it didn't really [__] matter
but it still got disturbed i'm like i
don't need to watch this i'm 58 years
old
a guy beating up a woman i it wasn't my
type of show i already watched [__]
the punisher
you know i've watched everything guys
you sit there at night you watch a
couple move there's one show that
there's one channel that saves me all
the time it's called
this no it's called this be et2 because
bt always got boomerang on at least once
a week or they deliver with harlem
nights i ain't mad at bt power to the
people
b t is my world because every week they
either hit you with hustle and flow
[__] uh hustle and flow
[Music]
boomerang
the temptations move no that's always on
vh1 joey get it together that's how i'm
vh
they got boomerang and they got holly
harlem knights [__] tremendous bd i
love it i love that they have those
movies on you know i watch harlem nights
at beginning when eddie murphy kills the
dude the toothless [__] that's
my favorite [__]
uh boomerang i love to watch the chris
rock scenes i've seen the movie 50
[__] times but i love the chris rock
scene i like when they're in the gym
working out
and uh
and uh [__] uh
the one guy asked the one guy if he got
a piece of [__] yet the funniest guy
from he's he's a bad [__] and i
always forget what his name is brother
it was martin lawrence eddie murphy and
the third guy this guy was a bad derrick
so whatever he has three names they're
on the treadmill whatever the [__] you
call that thing with aurora and also he
cracks the black dude david alan greer
and david allen greer starts rolling
that [__] thing he's so hot and then
he's like relax relax
all that [__] is [__] natural comedy
but back to what the [__] was i talking
about we're talking about the
the this the this
they got like hard times from once they
they tune you up once a week but last
week they broke my heart because enter
the dragon was supposed to start at nine
o'clock there was nothing else on i went
to watch enter the dragon i wanted to
watch it just the beginning the the
[__] when he smacks the chinese kid
in the head and i wanted to see when he
fights [__] the guy in the in the
challenge temple but it was something
else it was like double dragons these
white kids
on skateboards in the 80s
they cracked me so i switched it but i
started watching the [__] wire
i asked my wife he ever wants to why
she's like it's been a while like oh
dawg it's been such a while for me i
blacked out
i know one thing about the wire that
dominic lauren bardosi we had him on the
podcast i do his podcast from time to
time he was on there and i really forgot
next time he does the podcast that's the
[__]
episode we're doing is on the [__]
why how he got the job why
i don't know if you've seen the y you
haven't seen the one i'm up to like
episode
10 maybe 12 every night we've been
watching one or two episodes
guys i gotta be honest with you
it's up there with the [__] sopranos
i like it
the way better than
i like to show on whatever with the
speed heads and [__] you know
the one about new mexico when they're
down there making meth and [__] that was
okay for me
yeah i i i didn't bite the chomp there
for some reason
i'm really a sopranos guy but this
[__] wire is making me think twice
it's re-evaluating my [__] you know i
got overtaken by the paisans there for a
couple years but man
if uh you haven't seen the why i think
it's on hbo
mac or hbo i don't know what they would
even call the 1992 hp have you put hbo
on hbo latino hbo family hbo comedy hbo
[__] russia i'm lost with hbo i know
that i have that particular app on my
i used to take it on the road when i
wanted my little ipad so i i don't know
what the [__] it is
apm hbo max that's what it is but uh
talking about you know the sports
advisors
yeah and i still remember so 93
i finished
and then i went back
in 94
i went to work for one of their friends
for a few weeks during the summer
[__] up guy he broke away from them
and then my man
kurt called me and he goes hey
you can't work for that dude
because how much you want a week because
they you know the first year they give
you a guarantee versus
commission so he asked me i told him a
number and he goes done
come to work i was like what so i'm
gonna make some money my 94.
by 94 i started gaining time on my
comedy
i started [__]
you know i had 20 minutes i had opened
up for carlos mancia
with the local slam comedy we did a two
or four cities
that gave me a little confidence
i was also getting a lot more love
from the comedy works
uh i was done i had gotten fired from
the
boulder broker
the year earlier so i was out of there
on tuesdays i didn't have that
commitment anymore but it was time for
me to [__] move on that wasn't a job
forever anyway
and now i was out there doing spots
every [__] night
sunday through [__] thursday i was
out there plus
mckelvey's gave me guest sets during the
weekend so how did he do mckelvey's or
would send i had a bag of dick at wits
hens plus i started there as a doorman
plus the owner didn't like me so once i
ate a bag of dicks there he cut me off
in that club so on the weekends i would
just do four sets at
but at the same time i was starting to
pick up weekend work bill bowell was
taking me to wyoming
my career was on a [__] move jack
you know i was doing greely on thursday
nights now i didn't have to do that
[__] italian guys restaurant anymore
i was getting better bookings i was
making fifty dollars a show now
so i was making a little bit of [__]
money at night
and then uh
there was this booker named david
tribble
and
that's where you graduate you know i'm
sure there's a booker around here
when your band gets together it's not
the tour of lightning it's not you know
the guy that it's not roger graham
whatever his name is out of san
francisco
this guy's name is louis lepke he's
probably missing a [__] eye
he he chisels you on every [__] gig
when you get there they're not paying
they send a check 45 days later each
musician can only get three beers
food is uh full price but [__] you're
gonna give [__] blood if you eat it you
know there's a thousand [__] stories
that's what it is dog i know the comedy
world so i know how the comedy [__]
world works and the first year is just
atrocious and you work for horrific
[__] people
so uh
i had been the house emcee at the broker
the broker was a triple run on tuesday
nights wednesday you had off thursday
greely
friday
or something underneath
a crested butt across the butte crested
butte was friday then you ended up in
colorado springs on saturday and it was
an okay run it sucked dick with my line
to
uh you know he had a dry [__] eight
hours in between you gotta hit a [__]
deer
so i was a house emcee and he was
hearing things about me and i finally
had the balls to send them like a tape
that august
and i never heard from them so i
remember sending a tape
to this other comedy duo dana and doug
mcgraw out of [__] nebraska i had
taped this set
at a club mix this was a like a a black
club that was a gang club
and you i would go down every sunday
they gave me love it was on east kofax
you kidding me or what
so i would go to every [__] sunday
night and that was me
and uh
the vet from animal planet were the only
white dudes they liked
so we'd go down there we'd open up the
[__] show
but you know who was coming up then
cedric
d.l hewgley you know all these guys were
getting flown in there on sunday nights
and i was opening for them and meeting
them kwame i mean i met so many [__]
people that were great then the the club
ended because there was a shootout and
there was no more comedy i went up there
on monday there was [__]
those things everywhere there was cops
there they shot two people it was
tremendous tremendous always gives that
comedy room an edge
i dare you to sell on that [__]
so
i was having a good [__] time doing
comedy i was making money with them now
i was supposed to stay that year
i was gonna give it a shot until
final four basketball i had a job
kurt told me i could keep my job till
final four basketball
i was very happy i was gonna make two
extra months of money
by the time i got out of that office it
would be nice weather anyway i would go
to doing comedy
and
delivering [__] chinese food and if
you got to sell some coke
we do what we do i was in such a hole
back then guys
i couldn't get ahead if i was selling my
[__] for 10 you know i i would never
get ahead back then there was no way i
was in no [__] danger
of getting a head down
and uh
one i'd celebrate that remember that
christmas that [__]
i paid off all my bills and i was
waiting for like a check from a comedy
show i did that's what i'm talking about
i know all those [__] scams i did
like a show somewhere
at like a small college like one of
those ones that somebody calls you and
three people send you out there i don't
even remember who booked me in one of
those things
and when i got to they were like oh by
the way we sent you a check in the mail
signed the w9 i'm like god dammit how am
i going to get home i got no money for
[__] gas it was those type of gigs i
don't know if you anybody's ever
experienced those there was a contest in
seattle years later
it was on monday nights in tacoma
[__] tremendous room you had a win to
get 100 bucks i would go down there on e
i had no choice but to [__] win
and i would go up there with the energy
of 10 [__]
israel [__] whatever sharp shooters
and i'd [__] win every [__] monday
they gave you 100 that monday and 100 to
come back to follow on monday and host
who the [__] you think you're dealing
with joey bananas you know how you're
[__] around so
when you were allowed in seattle oh i
loved that that was that was before i
left seattle fun
wanted circumstances that we won't get
into you know i'm saying sometimes you
gotta go seattle was great to me it was
just time to move on to bigger pastures
los angeles and i'm happy i [__] did
so
you know i was scheduled to stay there
uh
i went through a rough christmas i paid
like a bunch of [__] in
the 15th like i said i didn't get my
christmas money
so i had to resort to pure [__]
vulgarity and
rob [__] toys r us from you know i
would go in there and
you know what was i gonna do i took a
christmas tree i mean you guys have
heard this it was just a horrible
christmas
i fronted chinese food from the chinese
place i deliver that and that was the
last time i had it for christmas i
remember that the christmas tree was
beautiful she had a bicycle she had and
let me tell you what's crazy the toys
that mercy likes are the ones i used to
give my daughter when she was younger
those [__] little houses that you
build and [__] my friend lisa brings him
for her and my other friend judy gives
them to her their old school toys she's
got the whole village up there
i remember giving her tons of those a
bike
i had i had no scotch tape so i put up
the silver [__] around the room with
duct tape yeah it was just you know
it was the last joey diaz christmas in
bold i didn't even know it
you know and that the new year came and
like
it was probably like the second week of
january one night i was not expecting it
it was freezing
and i got a call from david tribble
and he's like hey it's just joey diaz
i've heard good things blah blah blah
how much time do you have i didn't lie i
got like 24 minutes
he goes all right
he goes uh we're gonna start he goes i
gotta fall out in boulder
why don't you go down there tonight and
he goes if it all works out
i'll put you on the road i'll give you
some time i don't know if you guys knew
this story or not
so it was uh i'll never forget he called
on monday night football we were at a
bar
and he called me and that was like the
best day of my [__] life when triple
called me
if you know anything about me that was
it
i had [__] made it
you know in my mind like i had
[__] made it
scary
but i remember getting off the phone
with him
and my legs were kind of like wobbling
like i got hit in the head with a chair
i mean it was [__] crazy guys
this is what i wanted i did not want to
be a star i didn't want to be in movies
i just wanted triple and then the people
i told you dana mcgraw and doug mcgraw
they sent me a [__] i sent them a tape
they sent me a letter with like 100
check
and saying that they were going to hire
me as a co-headliner for 150th show
i was like what
and i got to call him back and go how do
i have
40 minutes of material he goes out we'll
burn that bridge when you get to it
start writing i swear to god
so here i went from [__]
three years of [__]
fighting my ex-wife
fighting her boyfriend
[__] going through a death
just horrible
emotional roller coaster every time i
had to drop my daughter off
they'd take her they pull off and i'd
sit there and [__] cry while i smoked
a [__] joint and i get my bearings to
me and i have to force myself to do
comedy
it was a tremendous [__] you know
looking back at it now i'm happy i
suffered i'm happy i put the time in
because when i got off that phone with
[__] david triple i was ready to go
so my mission was to
open up i wish i remember who i was
opening for it didn't matter
my job was just to go up there and do
great and i went up there and i
listen i knew the manager at the [__]
thing he liked me
but he also was trying to move up in the
company and he wanted to do other things
with triple so he really wasn't going to
lie to trouble for me you know i didn't
drink that night i didn't do no coke i
had everybody i knew come down
like all my friends in boulder to come
down they all came down they cheered me
on and he was like hey i'm gonna give
you a good report
i almost [__] died and i didn't hear
from tribble the next day i called them
the next day and thanked them for the
spot something i learned from stu finer
i called them and thanked them for the
spot cause this
all this [__] i was learning from stu
now i was using it towards my comedy
like i was calling people cold
cold call i didn't give a [__] about
calling the comedy producer you know
what i'm saying so
what stu was teaching me was going into
my comedy now
and i'll never forget i called him the
next morning it was like a wednesday
morning
i didn't hear back from him
i was [__] heartbroken as [__]
a week went by
two weeks went by
i remember calling dana and doug mcgrone
going i guess
i'm going up to nebraska
and he started giving me dates on the
phone he goes well at the present time
all i got is like one [__] week for
you and it was like this awkward week it
was gonna be like 90 miles a lot like 90
hours of driving
each gig he had he hadn't really put his
network together but each gig was an
average of 12 hours in between so you
basically had to do the gig get in your
car and drive 12 hours to and it was
spread out it was like
ogallala nebraska to [__] oh yeah
like it was going to take me 24 hours
just to get that type of [__] comedy
and then from ogallala i had to go all
the way up to like
something in north dakota and then there
was something in south dakota and it
ended up in like 50 miles from west
virginia
that's a [__] hall guys i don't take
a look at your [__] map because it
wasn't like now
let me see how many miles nah
in those days you didn't have that app
you had a [__] whatever map and when
you looked at that [__] and
pointed and went like that and it was
six inches and then you went over here
and it was six inches then you went down
it was six inches long every one of
those inches is a [__] nightmare so i
remember going what the [__] i go doug
can i call you back in a couple days and
give you an answer on this yeah yeah
yeah and out of nowhere
like on a [__]
monday night
at 10 o'clock i was at my uncle mike
kessler's house
we're probably about to cut into a
package
and my [__] pager went over
and it was the whatever the idaho
because he lived and i don't no no no no
he lived in uh vancouver washington
and he called me up and he's like joey
diaz okay david tribble and i remember i
was at a pay phone
i'd have a pen with me
i had nothing you know i just answered
the phone
and he's like joe diaz david tribble
i have uh
i have a nice run for you
six weeks
in a row
i almost [__] came in my [__] like
i was like holy [__]
this is exactly what i want he goes do
you have a phone number i can fax it to
you and thank god my uncle mike had
driven me to the pay phone
and he goes he's got a fax machine and
we [__] wrote down the number and he
sent the pages that night like an hour
late it was like 30 [__] pages of
gigs
i like 30 gigs in six weeks
it started with the potato run
[Music]
i was like what the [__] did i get
myself into but i didn't give a [__] i
was so [__] happy i could [__]
jump out a window man i was gonna live
my dream
you know i was [__] happy what was i
gonna do with my job
i still had to work for final four
basketball and all that [__]
so i was like [__] what am i gonna do
so i went to kurt like a man the next
day
and i told him the truth and he said
like
when are you leaving he goes then quit
that be your last day at least work till
then get as much money as you can put
away
and i [__]
took care of everything with my ex-wife
because i was coming back every sunday
there was no way i was staying out in
limbo for six [__] weeks you're out
there in [__] limbo guys
anyway listen if if i didn't have the
situation i had involved i would have
probably
i wouldn't mind staying out there for
six weeks that was that type of savage i
was gung-ho
it was 1995.
made me 32 years old
i had zero possessions in my life
i had a car that a guy lent me money to
buy
i had an apartment there was no zero
value
i had nothing saved i didn't have a
credit card
i had [__] nothing
i just had this car
and a desire to do [__] stand up i
had a pager
i had a basketball football a frisbee i
threw them all in the trunk of the
[__] car i had a blanket in there a
suit
i prepared myself for a road gig i
remember looking at doug stanhope's car
when he slept over my house like when i
first got separated he came back as a
headliner
and i looked at his [__] car and it
was just tremendous i'm like he had it
all sorted out and [__] a little cooler
so i did the same thing i copied what he
did except for the hanger across the car
i hit i had like a little sting and
i uh worked my last day for kurt
i had some money put away
and that it was like [__] february
mid february there was snow everywhere
and my first road gig
you [__] couldn't guess this
if you wanted to you want me to tell you
why i started my first [__] ever road
gig
you ready
rock springs wyoming [__]
that's where talent goes to [__] die
now let me tell you the funny thing
about rock springs wyoming before we get
into this [__] we won't be here for long
guys
i was watching i'm a big time [__] 60
minutes guy
i'm gonna tell you if i'm going to watch
it
after they come you know
this guy in europe is
selling [__] fire that you could
stick in your ass
what's his name is going to go visit him
then they're like and this guy you know
they always tell you the preview of the
show before it comes up you know and
they give it to you in the i like that
they tell you the truth you always know
what's going to be the first story on 60
minutes well i used to watch 16 minutes
and if it sucked i would put on fox and
watch house of buggin with john
leguizamo a lot of you [__]
don't even know what i'm talking about
look it up on youtube voguing for
congress it was john leguizamo and louis
guzman and a couple of [__] funny
cats from new york and fox gave him a
deal to build like a latino and living
color and it was okay but it didn't cut
the [__] mustard but john was good
and louis guzman was really good
so i was watching 60 minutes one night
and i remember i switched to watch
that [__] thing specifically
and it was
60 minutes was doing a thing about rock
springs wyoming
and the problems they had in rock
now you guys will not [__] believe
this
the government had to go in the feds i
guys google this [__] google rock
springs wyoming
google 16 minutes this is the type of
[__] that uncle joey's going to tell you
you know every some guy [__] hit me
like a year ago he's like every time i
listen to you i'm rogan
it was always something you were friends
with a drug dealer and aspen i was never
steve grebel's friend i just knew of him
in his antics and he got blown up by a
car bomb and aspen colorado when he was
coming out of the [__] aspen club i
was not friends with him i read about
the legend i had heard about him my
friend steve chavoni used to make them
chicken curry sandwiches on rye
at uh in and out sandwich place in aspen
colorado so i got info from him
with people like how do you come across
these [__]
ooh so anyway what we talking about
what we tell them
that's what the fart is it's to throw
you off a little bit that really wasn't
a tremendous thought that was more of a
rip people don't believe
don't believe the [__] hype so i got
to [__] rock springs was a place the
feds took
from the [__] mafia
the [__] mafia
was up in rock springs wyoming don't ask
me what family
don't ask me what organization i got no
idea i don't remember who the [__] they
were i remember sitting there they had a
p it all started with a pizza place
some guy went out there for a pizza
place and if you don't [__]
quote me on this i think the feds got
involved because the guy was in the
witness relocation plan
and he went up to rock springs wyoming
and created [__] havoc there was a
strip club up there i'm gonna forget
pulling into rock springs wyoming
and driving down the town
and [__] seeing
strip club upon strip club upon strip
club so i'm like what the [__] goes on
in rock springs so what i did the first
time i went there i drive to the
location of the gate
i go i'm gonna go see what the this
[__] hell hole looks like
i got that a hellhole was [__] great
it was just a bar with a lot of glass
you know like people they have the
glasses up on top and the bar then it
was i that's all i remember vaguely
big place nice stage
the whole thing i go and i introduce
myself they gotta look something like i
have three heads and he goes you from
new york and yeah there's a lot of
[__] people here from jersey in new
york now that you said that i'll make
calls they'll all probably be at the
[__] show tonight
i was very excited i go what do i do all
day goes well you can't check into the
whole telltale three
so if you want to go to a strip club
down the [__]
bottom of the corner so i i did what the
guy told me all right you know he goes
they serve lunch there you get a
sandwich tell them we sent you you're
the comedian they'll take care
i [__] go in this place creepy as
[__] smells like spiders
i don't even know what a spider smells
like
but if a spider smelled this is the club
that would smell like the [__]
cobwebs so
i get into this [__] place and
they're like there's like an open or you
could eat [__] for lunch and it was like
a buffet you know
it was all nasty food but when you're
[__] an opener and you got five
dollars in your
at that time i'm not gonna lie to you i
had that money put away from the sports
but i couldn't get to that they would
send you that once a month it was like a
stipend
and um
i went up there i had a couple [__]
dollars on me but how much can you have
at that time a hundred if i had 100 cash
it was burning all my pocket
[Music]
sorry about that it's a leftover covered
lung juice
so
i'll never forget that uh
i
walk into this place and i notice
something
that's very [__] weird real quick and
now for a word for my sponsors
what's happening guys the joint is
sponsored by better help online therapy
online therapy some people think you
should wait until things get unbearable
to go to a therapist that's not true
therapy is the tool that helps you avoid
these lows listen like i said on the
podcast i was going through my own stuff
withdrawing and stuff i was confused
about quitting comedy you know i just
needed to talk to somebody and
betterhelp.com was there for me i spoke
to dana and it was tremendous it's just
like going to the gym with a dentist we
should be caring for our mental health
as much of our physical health and
listen mental health
is uh going crazy right now but better
help is customized online therapy that
offers video phone and live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
have to see anyone on the camera if you
don't want it it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can start
communicating with your therapist in
under 48 hours give it a try and see why
over 2 million have used on better
health online therapy including your
uncle joey was sponsored by better help
and joint listeners get 10 off their
first month go to betterhelp.com
diaz that's better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com
slash diaz and check out better helps
new podcast getting better on apple
spotify and everywhere you get podcasts
thank you
we're back [__] anyway so i walk into
this club
and i see that's great i broke
to tell you guys
about betterhelp.com
but here i am telling you a story about
strip clubs and what led me to
betterhelp.com so it works out perfectly
so i walked into this [__] strip club
and i noticed something guys i wanted i
got a sandwich i didn't go in there to
pick nobody up guys i had no money i
didn't have the resources so why [__]
with somebody they said hello and do you
want to dance and all this [__] but
that's not what i was there for
so i [__] go in and i noticed
something
that every one of these girls
is a [__] nine
this is no joke this is not like a strip
club
anywhere before that i've been this is
a [__] these girls are hot and young
yeah they look a little different
so when i'm in there i start talking to
some guy you're from jersey yeah you go
to this strip club it's still [__]
two o'clock in the afternoon
i had to buy a beer to sit there like an
[__] i think i drank half of it was
disgusting i don't know what it was i
went to the other strip club and i
noticed in there
guys every woman in there was hot they
were like you know between 19 and 25
whatever
so i start talking to one of the guys in
there
and he's like i want to be [__]
gangster he's telling me all this [__]
that he moved from brooklyn and
he opened up the strip club with the
sandwich shop
and they're telling me that these chicks
they run them out in and out of vegas
but they running through rock springs so
after they go like on a tour of vegas
like they would go like let's say to the
bunny ranches
or one of those [__] houses they
would get [__] to death for about six
months
after the [__] out of whack and [__]
they would go to rock springs they would
do like well there was no cbd then but i
know some girl was telling me that day
that her friend is putting together a
cbd
vagina scrub to get your little monkey
back in shape and [__] so they would go
up there
do a little foliage tighten up the
[__]
get the stink off them of 60 days of
having disgusting sex with disgusting
fat dudes like myself i've never had sex
in vegas but i'm just telling you that
the guys are more disgusting than me
and they go up there and they kind of
like rehab them from the drugs i was in
[__] shocked that i'm hearing this
[__] no this isn't surreal this is like
an episode
of [__] uh the twilight zone for a
guy like me
so finally i look up at the [__]
clock and it's a quarter of three i'm
like [__] it i went in my pocket because
they would send you a fax with the
hotels
that you were staying at the the bar
manager the name of the bar you were
performing at the guy's name who was
going to pay you how much you want to
pick up
and then uh you know the name of the
hotel blah blah blah the name of the
headliner
that week i didn't know who the
headliner was so i [__] get to the
hotel
the guy asked me for my license and [__]
i give it to him
and also the guy goes you're the
comedian he goes we got bad news
we uh
don't have hotel rooms we only have one
and you have to share it with the other
[__] comic
and guys there's nothing
i hate more than sharing a room with
another [__] man i didn't grow up
with a [__] brother okay
i didn't have no [__] brothers
you know the only people who slept in my
house are sister's
not my sister but i'm saying like a
woman that's it i never shed a bed with
a man
or i never was in a corner on the bed
over there it was very uncomfortable for
me but i couldn't afford a hotel room
anywhere else i mean this hotel was [__]
you could tell people had broken out of
that like it was just glasses were
broken and [__] when i got to my hotel
room i knocked on the door
the guy opened it he looked at me like
[__] he was waiting for a pizza
and that was one of the worst [__]
experiences of my life
on my first night of being a [__]
comic on the road
so for [__] three years i've been
going out there fighting
biting people working on material i
moved to new york for [__] nine
months and my first triple run
i gotta share a [__] room with a guy
i get dressed i go down to the [__]
gig
not only do i have to share a room with
a [__] dude but i eat the biggest bag
of dicks
i even remember the [__] manager like
rubbing my back like it's gonna be okay
i'll give you a good report i was ready
to [__] die
but that's just to let you know man that
uh
it was great and i'm i'm really happy
stu called up the other day i'm really
happy we got a great time
he educated us like the way he educated
me let me tell you how deep
that [__] sports thing got me to
nine we're talking about 98.
i'm in la
i'm at the store
yeah i booked the taco bell commercial i
ran some [__] money or whatever
ran into some money and that kept me you
know i was on [__] coke how long was
that gonna last me i blew it as fast as
it came in
and it was time to go look for a job and
i go you know what i can't believe i'm
[__] so i got a job i had to be there
at
five in the morning
six in the morning it was selling screws
and anchors
and [__] s-hooks and eye hooks and
you know
just everything everything i didn't want
to [__] sell
but when i was there i was there for
like three days i realized they gave you
a long distance act axis which you
didn't have anywhere else you had to pay
for it or buy a calling card and they
had a fax machine now if you guys
a lot of you guys don't know this back
then the way to get work was
to write out a month on a piece of paper
you know whatever with your hand listen
i didn't have a [__] computer so i
would just write it out my [__] hand
you write it out and you would send them
to bookers
you know i'm available it's called your
avails your availabilities and i'd send
them to el paso texas
the the two guys that booked michigan
i would send it to the improv cleveland
the improv miami the improv
texas you know i had like
it went from a list of two clubs to like
20 clubs and i would do this
every [__] day at that nail place
this is all the knowledge that i had
gotten from
colorado sports oh i didn't know how to
do any of this [__] but [__] what
four years later
in a complete different type of business
all those skills and i was calling those
club owners the way i was calling the
clients what's happening joey d is here
what's going on listen i got 15 minutes
i'm not looking to waste your [__]
time i need a guest spot you know why i
need a guest spot because once i get
there
i'm going to book that guest spot and
you're going to ask me to give me more
work
am i speaking to the manager that is
available to book
dog early on i was already closing
people on the phone am i speaking
with whoever is going to book me there
will he be there on sunday night i
figured out i created a speech
wrapped around comedy bookers and i was
doing the same aggressive stuff that
they had showed me in the sports betting
service
as comedy bookers and also i got into
[__] el paso i got into kansas city i
got into [__] the buffalo funny bone
all those clubs
i got in from what i had learned
calling i just called them and [__]
muscled them [__] and i'd say i'm
tough because i know but let me tell you
something in the beginning i didn't
notice in 93 what i failed to tell you
[__] was
for free i drove 16 hours rented their
own car on the [__] arm from me thank
god i knew a guy national [__] car
rental he lent me the car for two days
he charged me but i didn't have to pay
the full like 22 a [__] mile
but i drove all the way to [__] new
mexico
stayed in my car the guy let me stay in
the condo at night i drove all the way
back and do you know what he gave me
three weeks i was very proud of that i
booked three weeks i went up there i
earned it
what good would a three reside book that
right before i was going to do them all
three clubs were not a [__] business
phoenix new mexico and minneapolis all
[__] went out of business and that's
where the house of comedy is today see
you learn something on uncle joey's
joint [__]
so ever since that time
i think i did a guest set in michigan
when i was there to do joey's
i went up there i killed and when i got
off stage i went up to the guy i go so
when can i have a date and he goes
i'm not the guy that books the room i'm
going god damn it so now i made sure
before i came into the free [__] set
p on a sunday night that the comedy
booker was there
you don't want to miss this and i would
talk to him that way guys that's how
[__] out of my brain i would be you
don't want to miss this i'll be done if
and trust me i ate a lot of bags of dick
i ate a bag of dicks in the south bend
funny bone that was embarrassing i could
never even watch notre dame ever again
but it didn't [__] matter i muscled
them with what stew the system he had
put together i wish there was a way i
could teach you [__] maybe
we'll bother stew and see if we'll do
like an online class
and teach people how to be a [__]
savage because it's like the wolf of
wall street i was thinking about that as
i was talking to him like this guy's got
to do [__] uh
inspirational talk and teach people the
steps to [__] clothes people you know
most of you [__] walk around
and don't know how to close a
[__] that's what he taught me
how to close a [__] not think of
you yeah well i think about it [__] you
think about it i'm here
either give me the [__] get it so
tell me no
anyway
that's january the 12th it's a beautiful
[__] wednesday as you can tell
[__] i'm feeling good i'm
looking good i can't even start to tell
you how bad a [__] shape i was at
this time last year i was just coming
out of surgery down here drooling eating
[__] those oxycodones which almost
killed me
but i did it with your help
betterhelp.com
and uh
i still talk to them i feel [__]
great as you guys could tell i started
taking my alpha brain during the new
year
the first week of the podcast was a
little off i think i was still
recovering from covert brain but i'm not
here to apologize
[__] you [__] uncle joey's back
it's 2022 we're changing things around
we're making different videos and you
know it was just uh
i was in a bad place guys
i'm happy i opened up about it told you
guys what i was going through it made it
easier it opened up a lot of doors for
me and here we are today wednesday
january 10th ready to sling dick and
give out [__] chopsticks like a
[__] that's it and that's that
we'll be back monday morning
tip top magoo do not forget you got the
wild card this week and a lot of [__]
going on you got patreon five ten
dollars whatever the [__] you want to
throw we're back building over there
we're working on the album of the week
we're working on figuring out a way how
we can blow smoke through your [__]
speakers
and get you knowing that we're just
trying to be better from all angles as
you can see here today we switched
everything around i got some new
pictures here
and a new picture new year new attitude
after mike leaves them to kill a few
chickens and get this party take the
[__] and speed those mallows out of the
[__] room
and that's it and that's that i love you
[__]
with all my heart i'll see you monday
morning
tip top magoo and now for a word for our
[__] sponsors jack
all right you bad [__] thank
you for tuning in today we had a little
nice
tate but before i go remember what i
told you during the show the joint is
sponsored by better health online
therapy some people think you should
wait until things get bad no no
that's not true therapy is the tool that
helps you avoid these lows listen you
take your car for a tune-up right your
brain needs to tune up you from time to
time mental health has been rough on a
lot of people i didn't know i thought i
was the only one that had some problems
during this pandemic but there was
others
but i went to betterhelp.com and i got
together with dana
and here i am you know six seven eight
months later it's like going to the gym
with a dentist you should be caring for
your mental health as much as your
physical health i didn't know this
either better help is customized online
therapy
that offers video phone and live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
have to see anyone or can't you have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can start
communicating with your therapist in
less than 48 hours give it a try and see
why over 2 million people have used
better help online therapy we're
sponsored by better help and joint
listeners i'm going to get you 10 off
your first month at
betterhelp.com
diaz d-i-a-z
that's better help b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com
slash diaz and check out better helps
new podcast getting better on apple
spotify and everywhere else you get a
podcast the joint is also brought to you
by expressvpn
listen how are you going to go on the
internet and not have expressvpn you
have an alarm in your house right you
got a chastity belt for your wife right
but why do that yeah you might be safe
but chances are before you know it
somebody's tapping into your computer
stealing your personal information it
doesn't take much to know how to hack
someone i think they just got a kid that
was 12 or something like that that's why
you got to go with expressvpn i've had
it for years my wife used it sometimes
if you want to go into the dark web
that's where you got to go it's is it
fast it's tremendous and it's easy to
use
but expressvpn hackers can't steal your
sensitive data i take a hacker with a
super computer over a billion years to
get fast express vpn's encryption who's
better than expressvpn nobody
sorry about that it's easy to use
fire up the app click a button to get
protected and it works on all devices
phones laptop tablets and much much more
so you can stay secure on the go
secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com
joey that's expressvpn.com
joey j-o-e-y
and you can get an extra three months
for free just use my name expressvpn.com
joey i know you got paid last week
i know you got paid on monday night
unlike your uncle joey i had [__] uh
alabama for the small 25 but at least i
got the watch ticket anyway draftkings
is here to rock your [__] world for
the wild card weekend it's 56 to 1 odds
just better finn to win 280 and free
bets if you fit if your team is [__]
victorious who gives you those numbers
plus you got uncle joey here plus you
got a social network on here plus you
got a stats hub here they do everything
you can to help you win a little [__]
money nobody does that now if you got a
gambling palm you got to go somewhere
else because there's no gambling
problems here this is gambling for fun
they got a casino they got blackjack
they got baccarat they got roulette they
got it all over at draftkings so do
yourself a favor if sportsbook isn't
available in your state yet you still
got something to play
for this wild card weekend plus you got
nba basketball college basketball
everybody can play for huge cash prizes
with draftkings daily fantasy football
contest
draftkings is giving all new customers a
free shot at millions of [__] dollars
with a first deposit where you gonna get
that action from you know you love your
[__] fantasy [__] download the
draftking sportsbook app today right now
and use promo code joey j-o-e-y and get
56-1 odds on any [__] nfl team
just spend five dollars and win 280 in
free bets if your team wins that's promo
code joey this saturday and sunday wild
card weekend at draftkings the special
the official sports betting partner of
the nfl you bad [__] now you
got to be 21 older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania colorado new york city new
customers only minimum five dollar
deposit and a dollar wager one per
customer restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook
for details now if you've got a gaming
palm i want you to chill
call 1-800 gambler take care of yourself
but if you're together if you're
straight head to draftkings win some
[__] getus and get your [__]
kakucha suck this weekend like a pimp
that you are [__]
i want to thank betterhelp.com
expressvpn
draftkings
i want to thank cbd lion honett
lucy gum you know you guys are all
manscaped for saving ball and [__]
and people's lives i love you
[__] i'll see you monday
morning
tip top magoo have a great weekend
[Music]
so
you